foreign
[Music]
check yeah yeah I got an interesting
explainer for you okay yeah I mean you
mean this one's going to be interesting
unlike all the other yeah you said that
like it was a qualifier
that that uh that did not previously
exist there's a feature of the James
Webb Space Telescope that I haven't seen
talked about much people only just think
of it as some next big telescope that's
out there in space bringing us badass
images but there's certain engineering
scientific features
that are unique with it that I think are
worth calling out okay okay that sounds
good if you can hang with me on this all
right allow me to remind us
that unlike Hubble which orbited Earth
360 miles up this thing is parked
A Million Miles Away
in the opposite direction of the sun
from the earth it's pretty wild okay
yeah and so I say parked we're all or it
and the Earth are orbiting the Sun
together and
so it so basically if you look back in
the earth Direction the sun will always
be there so it's it's using the Earth as
sunblock
well it has some motion where it is okay
but it's not going to drift away from
that location even though there's some
movement within the location the the
point is occasionally Earth will block
the Sun but the value of this is you
always know which way the sun is right
at all times okay
behind you okay right all right I'm
looking out to space the only way to
take good pictures
and what they say like good one yeah
it's true behind you that's right that's
right so then everyone is squinting as
they look in there exactly right
so if you're going to take a picture of
something that's dim
you either have to illuminate it
yourself
which we really can't do for the early
the universe that doesn't work or you
can take a long exposure
to allow the light to accumulate but
while you're taking that warming
exposure you can't jiggle the camera it
has to be perfectly stationary so Chuck
just to repeat we can't take a flash
picture of the outer universe so we have
to open the exposure for a long time
okay so now watch uh different
bands of the electromagnetic spectrum
tell us different things about the
universe
right so if you're going to do that you
need telescopes that specialize in the
chosen band and by the way we didn't
even know light came in bands other than
visible light
and somebody had to discover that I mean
just think about it why would you have
any inkling
why would you believe at all
that there was a kind of light out there
that your eyes could not detect right
especially if you're religious right if
you're religious what God Made You men
said we have eyeballs to see light and
how could there possibly be something we
can't see all right so there's certain
expectations of who and what we are as a
life form that we're completely overrun
the day infrared light was discovered
okay did I tell you how they discovered
infrared I tell you uh-huh but it was it
did William Herschel discovered okay
tell the story okay real quick okay
thinking of something else I'm like okay
William Herschel discovered it and uh
how do you do it he he knew that Isaac
Newton figured out that white light is
composed of colors you just pass it
through a prism and it breaks it apart
so he repeated this experiment you put a
little slit of light in your room but
the whole room has to be dark so that
only the spec shows up all right and you
pass it through a triangle prism you get
a rainbow on your table and there it is
red orange yellow green blue violet and
he had the foresight
to ask the question
I wonder if the different colors of
light have different temperatures
yeah just to just to even ask that
question which is pretty uh pretty
impressive question think about that
it's a simple question maybe
retrospectively obvious but at the time
okay so what does he do he has a
thermometer and puts it in each of the
different colors of light
but wait a minute you need a control
thermometer so he took his control
thermometer put it off to the side just
to the just to the side of the red okay
so that was not in the Spectrum all
right and he that would presumably just
measure room temperature all right but
it was still on the table where he was
measuring the rest of the temperatures
your control has to have a minimum of
variation other than the one thing you
want to change okay so the thermometer
is on the table but just off to the side
and so there he is he's measuring the
temperature of blue and red and yellow
and and what he's finding
is that the thermometer off to the side
is consistently measuring higher
temperature than all the rest of the
thermometers all the rest of the
readings that he was taking
and he said WTF I'm sure that's what he
said okay
I am sure and right after that he went
OMG
OMG
WTF
all right so he publishes this paper
and it's just it's beautiful in how he's
tiptoeing around a discovery
because he doesn't really know he said
he could there be light
that is unfit for vision
unfit for this this is how he described
it that's a great description and he
does this enough and he's I think I've
discovered light unfit for vision you
damn right you did and it was it's light
below the red and what do we call it
infrared okay and it's so funny you
still see the hubris of human
um uh existence there it's unfit for
vision not we can see
we blind to this thing exactly it's got
the problem it's not the problem now
it's unfit for us it's unfit for vision
I've thought about it that way very good
so so it turns out so that's just an
interesting sort of Discovery experiment
and then we would learn well if that
exists maybe other bands of light exist
and so thus thereafter we would discover
ultraviolet
microwaves radio waves X-rays and each
have their moment in the Sun so to speak
and that fills out the the entire what
we call electromagnetic spectrum only a
small fraction is visible light and so
so now you're going to say what in the
universe gives off infrared light and
you find out that things that have kind
of any temperature at all will radiate
in the infrared
okay now so for example if you have an
electric stove and you put it on low and
turn out all the lights can you see it
no not if it's on low but you put your
hand on it you'll burn your hand okay so
something to me about it something is
coming out of the stove and it's not
unfit for vision right it's infrared
light okay and when you think it's hot
enough it's not only giving off infrared
it'll begin to also give off visible
light right okay but if the thing is
cool enough it's primarily only going to
be giving you infrared suppose you want
to see infrared all right and by the way
infrared doesn't make it very nicely
through Earth's atmosphere you know how
you know this
because we have greenhouse gases that
trap the infrared that is down here okay
so the greenhouse effect are molecules
that have a special relationship with
infrared and there's the ground trying
to radiate infrared back into space he
said no you don't and it sends it back
down and accumulates okay so here's the
cool thing about the James Webb
Telescope it has a special reflective
surface on its mirrors
that are tuned to reflect infrared with
very high efficiency that's number one
reflect and focus number two if you're
trying to detect something that is a
very low temperature
what happens if you have a temperature
and you're the detector you end up
detecting yourself exactly
you can't have that that's what you want
it for the universe and all I found was
me
so so you need a way to cool the
telescope so we could send up cryogenic
liquids and things but they would
eventually evaporate or or gain
temperature and that so what we figured
out to do we not I the engineers who
were tasked with this
um that telescope has a series of
thermal baffles
between it and the Sun
all right and so those just take a look
at any photo of the full telescope
deployed these these they're basically
screened they're like sheets that are
that are put up a series of of them in
the row so sunlight comes and hits one
of them it reflects some back
others get absorbed and gets
re-transmitted to the next sheet but
that gets recent back there's this
multiple triple Reflections and at each
layer the amount of heat from the Sun is
dramatically dropped
okay dramatic by the time it comes out
the other side is barely there at all
and so the temperature of the telescope
can now drop
to what is basically the temperature of
deep space without any influence of
sunlight
uh uh increasing its its body
temperature if you will that's wild
totally wild so now the James Webb Space
Telescope can observe deep in the
infrared part of the spectrum because it
can
and so there you have it that a little
primer on infrared and infrared
telescopes and how that works well there
you go people I hope you're paying
attention because you're going to be at
a cocktail party where this is going to
come very very handy
I plan on using it this weekend I'm
telling you right now
it's what's that skirt for on the outer
edge of the telescope
I suppose you didn't realize that there
were baffles that I filled to the
sunlight in such a way that cools the
telescope so that we're able to register
the infrared without registering the
heat from the telescope itself yes this
is the kind of stuff you learn when
you're an extremely smart individual by
the way off with you okay
that's why you don't have any friends
left at your party
all right that's all the time we have
for this explainer Chuck that was good
all this stuff all right Neil deGrasse
Tyson here keep looking at it
[Music]